c'est la capitale du pétrole ou pis et
aujourd'hui vous formerez se réjouit de
voir son plus grand défenseur élus et 5
nuls va mieux s'occuper de nous dit cet
employé de cing crude le travail mais
aussi d'autres villes canadiennes
donc c'est de ramener c'est de ramener
le travail de faire sortir le pétrole si
les électeurs ont donné un mandat clair
à jason kenny ils attendent sont énormes
s'inspirant de son ami d'oxford en
ontario il a lancé un message aux
investisseurs
l'alberta se montrera plus accueillante
pour les gens d'affaires
teyssen kenny promet de se battre sur
tous les fronts pour obtenir de nouveaux
pipelines
si le québec et les autres provinces
province vous n'acceptez les transferts
fiscaux massive promenant de l'alberta
alors s'il vous plaît aidez-nous à
développer nos ressources naturelles et
notre économie
il veut aussi baisser les impôts des
entreprises et abolir la taxe sur le
carbone instaurée par le gouvernement
note lee à calgary ville qui a beaucoup
souffert depuis la chute des prix du
pétrole
plusieurs accueille la victoire de jason
kenny avec un enthousiasme modéré cet
entrepreneur serais content de voir ces
taxes baissé mais il doute que
l'élection des conservateurs agissent
comme une baguette magique
économiquement il n'a pas le contrôle
sur le prix du pétrole
et ça va être vraiment difficile de
convaincre les autres des autres
provinces de construire ses pipelines de
faire en sorte que de revenir aux belles
années enfin c'est un peu les promesses
d'un peu la poudre aux yeux je trouve ce
politologue crois que le chef
conservateur a peut-être trop premier
aux albertains
même si dans les prochaines semaines
l'expansion du pipeline trans l'antenne
entre l'alberta et la colombie
britannique pourrait être approuvé
ironiquement dit-il jason kenny pourrait
profiter du travail de déblocage
accompli par woodson attelé justin
trudeau dans ce dossier là la chef néo
démocrate
relégué dans l'opposition promet de
défendre son bilan santé en éducation
elle se battra pour les moins nantis et
pour le respect des minorités sexuelles
le npd moi-même demeureront vos
champions at elle conclu après sa
défaite